servus und herzlich willkommen aus
verdient ich bin heute morgen nach
ziemlich genau zweieinhalb stunden
schlaf nach berlin geflogen weil ich
hier von premiere eingeladen wurde den
store zu besuchen und nicht nur das
sondern ich darf mit über ein paar
schuhe und ein rucksack mitnehmen und
die beiden nach paris bringen
heute abend um 18 uhr geht mein flug von
berlin nach paris und ich bin ehrlich
gesagt mega mega aufgeregt liefen jetzt
auf jeden fall zum privater store in
berlin wo die schule abholen den
rucksack ab
nein
gute kleine in lassen der vor gut ein
kleiner händler sind es soll zwar
gestoppt
okay leute
wir haben den rucksack da sie an
und jetzt beginnt die reise für mich
heute abend um 18 uhr fliegt nach paris
jetzt haben wir kick der rx zu lang
jetzt haben wir fünf nach 24 stunden
flug bis dahin muss ich noch mal zum
flughafen
so leute unsere kleine mittagspause zum
geld eben doch was gegessen und jetzt
gehts eigentlich auch schon weiter zum
flughafen wir haben jetzt halb fünf am
meer um zehn nach sechs also eine stunde
40 geht mein flug und wir müssen vorher
noch eine sache die ganz wichtig ist
machen und zwar muss den rucksack
dekorieren einmal äußerlich dafür habe
ich mir gedacht hängen wir daraus ein
polaroid kann dafür schon eine kamera
ausgeliehen
led könig war sie einmal in einmal außen
außen mit dem chor reutin packen wir das
wollen wir jetzt eine einwegkamera ist
das sowas soll es angeblich geben
wir sorgen uns im tal 27 bilder
praktisch gerade mal aus macht dann hier
vom fernsehturm nochmal ins bild
sechseinhalb stunden später
heute könne mich hören
gerade eben das müsst ihr euch
vorstellen
minuten vor abflug
achtung
das nächste abenteuer guckt euch mal
diese rolltreppe anders ist das sind wir
hier in fucking freizeit heute sind im
freizeitpark als wärest du wasserrutsche
unter fakt ist dass und das ist ihm
wackelt so sieht s
ich bin richtig meine leute ich habe
tatsächlich im flieger von berlin nach
paris getroffen und zwar den ton und
felix und wollte ihn grüßen
die roma felix offen
also just lukas aber ich bin auch größer
aus hallo ich fest felix
fuchs fein so und das liebe leute ist
für pariser verhältnisse ein sehr
ordentliches hotel dusche coors light
das werk paris muss man nämlich wirklich
aufpassen bei einem hier scheiße für
gold verkauft oder states angeht
aber ich habe glücklicherweise ein
cooles erwischt hier sieht schön aus
okay leute das war's soweit meine
anreise nach paris ich mache jetzt
erstmal bisschen frisch glaube ich dann
gehe ich hab ich immer raus wenn wir
seine lande französische bier und gibt
es essen morgen treffe ich die justine
joli französische youtube
die sind uns jetzt gleich wieder für
mich morgen früh
morgen
okay wir sind gerade hier da war ein
hotel
hier kann man wozu nicht gut frühstücken
dass wir gleich machen und nachher
treffen wir uns unten hier am trocadéro
direkt beim eiffelturm mit der
französischen youtube
alter leute ist über so fucking geil und
ich möchte etwas zu sagen aber das
bisschen ernster zu 2 ich bin einfach
ich gerade mega dankbar dafür dass ich
jetzt gerade hierdurch paris schlendern
darf es einfach geiles alles perfekt
irgendwie danke an euch dass ihr quasi
meine videos anschauen dass ich deswegen
solche guten sache machen kann
a
abbou
wir sitzen in einem kleinen café und wir
haben die zweite rucksack eingetroffen
das ist johanna und das ist ihre
schwester jennifer und den beiden werde
ich jetzt den rucksack darüber geben wie
bringen sie dann weiter nach spanien
bringen
the back to make it right hab hier noch
bisschen zeit ist jetzt halb vier
der turm ist erfordern die ecke heißt
schon was für normale leute das war dann
wahrscheinlich auch
oder meines lebens wir haben einfach
keine cola sechs euro ziehen bezahlt ist
eine 0 33 liter cola 6 eur 10
okay leute die haben es gerade ungefähr
dreiviertel stunde lang den
hütchenspielern zugeschaut
jetzt wollen auch mal genug auch in
faszinierend ist
leute das kapitel paris langsam dem ende
zu der wir gerade eben ein bisschen spaß
gab mit den bildern
das ist johanna und das sind wir beide
auf jeden fall haben wir ungefähr
eineinhalb stunden vom eiffelturm
gezählt aber jetzt ist zeit sozusagen
habt ihr schon mal so'n lehrern
flughafen gesehen das terminal 2 gegen
ausgelagert ist das licht geht aus und
es war glaube ich der letzte flug von
diesem terminal den ich jetzt in meiner
frankfurt mit diesem lernen flughafen
der erste den ich jemals gesehen habe
ändert auch der heutige blog ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen eigentlich noch mal
an prämie dafür dass von einer mega
wirklich habe mir echt gut gefallen und
wir sehen uns bald wieder biss dann